the time's up movement came to life
nearly two years ago when more than 300
powerful women in Hollywood took a stand
against sexual harassment in the
workplace its mission is to ensure
equity and safety in the workplace
across all industries it's responding to
survivors who came forward through the
me2 movement CBS corporation donated 20
million dollars last year to advocacy
groups working to end sexual harassment
in the workplace including time's up
only on CBS this morning times up is
announcing the organization's new leader
she is here at the table just slipping
in she's co-founder of times up Legal
Defense Fund and the former chief of
staff to First Lady Michelle Obama Tina
Chen joins us first on CBS this morning
congratulations and welcome Ellie oh
thank you thank you I could not be more
thrilled to be able to take this job
what why are you thrilled because
there's been a couple of hiccups you
know they're there four months ago we
had to make a change at the top and now
you are here what's your biggest
challenge I want to know why you're so
thrilled I saw you back when you were
getting ready and thrilled would be the
word to describe you the relative thrill
did it well yeah I've been living these
issues my whole life wouldn't have been
a single working mom my entire career
working in places like law firms and the
White House so I've seen the issues that
women confront in workplaces and I've
been working on gender equity issues for
over three decades what's your biggest
challenge you think as you sit here
today well you know we need to change
companies and workplaces you know this
is still happening it's been three
decades since the Supreme Court outlawed
sexual harassment and yet here we are
today right when they with that wait
co-founded the times up Legal Defense
Fund I did which which has raised over
twenty four million dollars is that
right that's right what's what's that
mean money being used for it's being
used to help victims of sexual
harassment you know so many have
actually no recourse to legal services
especially low-income women they can't
find lawyers to represent them when
they've been sexually harassed they
can't find PR support when their names
all of a sudden start appearing in the
news so we've been able to help over
3,600 individuals in the last two years
who've come forward and a lot of
two-thirds of them are low-income women
they come from every industry in the cut
tree you mentioned changing workplace
culture your law firm or you were part
of the group focused on that I did I
started it what did you learn from that
effort that you can take forward into
this new job well what I learned is this
is what's happened in the last two years
since the first time avoiding articles
is there is when companies coming
forward with in a willingness that has
never happened before to actually think
about these issues they see the risk to
their companies if they don't address
these issues they also see the benefits
and so I've seen an openness by
companies but here's the thing
they actually don't know what to do and
that's why one of the things I mean
we're excited about in conjunction with
my announcement is to announce Melinda
Gates has given us a generous donation
to start an impact lab generous well
it's a lot but the first you know of
what we hope will be more because we
need to build research and but we don't
know what works with these or always
comes criticisms because it's been two
years since the organization was
launched there are grumblings that it's
become very cliquey very disorganized
that women are just using it as a
networking opportunity but now you are
the new sheriff in town what do you have
to say about those concerns well
actually it's not just than that you
know we've been active with the times of
legal defense fund we've been active and
advocating for policy change so just a
couple of weeks ago folks from times up
were with Governor Cuomo when he signed
the New York safety agenda that changed
laws here in New York you know to help
protect victims of sexual assault we
started something called who's in the
room out in Hollywood to actually
provide a mentoring program for young
women and people of color trying to
break their way be part of the solution
that's what role should men be playing
now well here's the thing 95% of Fortune
500 CEOs are men that's right if men
aren't part of the solution we're not
gonna fix this so men you know need to
own this as an issue if you're a CEO
this needs to be your issue not just
your HR department your board of
directors needs to own the issue and
what's the issue it's about building
workplaces that are safe respectful and
equitable to everyone and making sure
that women have more power and influence
Tina Chen good luck in your new gig oh
thank you
thanks so much for being here this
morning